her old-time rivals arena crush tatev
she has a score on you that's just epic
she's like a big winning score how does
it feel to take her down in this last
game oh it feels amazing it's my first
time beating her with black i think
she's beating me with the white pieces
every single time
wow it's a big result what happened that
caused it in the game where was her
mistake uh it was very complicated game
um
it's not there
she blundered her bishop got trapped and
she didn't have to get a drought
apparently
but like somewhere yeah somewhere around
here
takes takes knight g3
you know bishop before and i so here's
sort of queen f6 i was calculating i
thought this bishop should get lost
somehow i was calculating king h8
like with the idea of just queen e7 and
winning something but then i thought she
can take on g7
and then i don't know if it works or not
but it was just too scary too scary
takes on queen h5 and i don't know oh
dear
i don't know if this works
but it's so easy to get lost in this
variation like my bishop on b4 is now
stranded
none of your pieces is anywhere near
your king
maybe a queen showing up but rook g1
check and rick
yeah this looks very scary so so i
thought i'm getting made it here so i
played queen f6 and
oops kind of consolidated but i thought
here i should be better but i just
didn't know how
so where did she get her bishop trap or
what what happened in the game
yeah so here
okay so tactically i have rookie 3 she
cannot take on g7 so we trade
yeah yeah so which rate
and rookie two now i'm threatening take
and like her bishop is just getting
trapped so apparently she has this
bishop a1 move and then a3 bishop c3 but
she didn't find it i didn't say it
either
but she went bishop c1 and i just um
i trade rooks rupee one and the bishop
is trapped
wow wow that simple
wow oh my goodness amazing
and you went on to win
all right well you got that monkey off
your back
uh
so
the tournament didn't go as you would
expected but your score
i feel like every time you're sitting
down here you won a game well that's the
only time
but i've seen you a few times
three games you won your last three
exactly so you did great in the comeback
trail where did you end up fifth place
maybe uh tie for for it tied for fourth
even
that's a pretty good result considering
the way you started the last place for
like most of the tournament yeah i mean
this has been a great turnaround for me
and a lot of good things about the
tournament too i think some playing some
new openings managing my time better so
i think there's some positive lessons
learned remember nice payday
absolutely and what are you going to
take from this for the next time um i
think i realize the work that needs to
be put in
to play in this tournament i just cannot
get away with just kind of showing up
and relying on my repertoire and just
kind of doing pride during the
tournament i think
it's kind of was a reminder of the work
that needs to go in months and months
prior to this tournament
all right we're looking forward to you
getting your first championship get that
focus in congratulations on a fine
finish thank you
indeed a very nice victory in these
championships